dans cette petite salle d'entraînement
de saint paul dans le nord de l'alberta
colton selon prince est destinée en main
chaque séance d'entraînement le
rapproche de son but devenir l'homme le
plus fort au monde
comme hiver quand une seconde se décrit
comme une grosse ourson en peluche de 6
pieds 3 pouces et 330 livres
saviez dicté par sa passion pour le
sport et son régime spartiate chaque
jour ils doivent aller au moins 7000
galerie pour maintenir sa condition
physique et continuer ses exploits
depuis octobre il est considéré comme le
premier sport professionnel autochtones
de l'histoire canadienne
il se réjouit que ces efforts n'ont pas
été en vain le parcours de culte selon a
toujours été parsemé d'embûches obtenir
cette cité est une raison de plus pour
lui de s'accrocher
cotation doit son salut à ce sport
sa passion lui permet de faire le deuil
de ses proches et de sa femme décédée du
cancer ce printemps
les voteurs
l'athlète trouve réconfort dans la fonte
il souhaite maintenant transmettre ce
message aux autres
curieux prochaine étape pour l'amfar les
états unis à la fin du mois alors qu'il
tentera de se qualifier pour une place
au championnat du monde ici julien la
traverse saint paul